In lecture, Dave pointed out that these 2 functions,
hashtable_update and hashtable_lookup,
use some similar functionality
that instead we could place in a separate procedure.
Looking at the hashtable_update and lookup procedures here,
we see code that's identical between them, namely these 2 lines.
In both functions, these 2 lines of code go through a given bucket
searching for an entry whose first value is the key.
And so what we're going to do is we're going to take this code
and move it into a separate helper function.
This is known as refactoring.
Refactoring is a common software engineering practice
where we change the code without changing the functionality.
There's a number of reasons to do so.
For example, here we're doing it to minimize duplicated code.
This is desirable, because if we want to change how these 2 lines of code work--
perhaps we change the structure of the bucket--
we don't want to look through every hash table function
searching for how this works and updating them.
Rather, we just want to update it in 1 place.
This minimizes bugs and saves time. So let's give it a try.
Here I've created a new function called bucket_find.
You should see that it's very similar to the code that we have in update and lookup
in that we're going to go through the bucket searching for the entry
whose first value is the key and then returning the entire entry
so that we can use it accordingly in both update and lookup.
So now that we have the helper function, let's change our hash table functions to use it.
The resulting code is going to be both simpler and shorter.
I've changed hashtable_update.
We find the bucket in the first line,
then within the bucket we're searching for the key,
and if we find that entry we're going to update the value.
Otherwise we're going to append the key and the value to the end of the bucket.
It looks quite a bit simpler than the original function.
Let's do the same thing to lookup.
In the new hashtable_lookup, we first find the bucket
and then within the bucket we search for the entry.
If the entry is not None, we return the second value.
Otherwise we return None.